c'est devenu le repaire des trafiquants
de drogue des allers retours incessants
des affrontements entre bandes rivales
des coups de feu plusieurs habitants de
cette zone résidentielle des plans cette
situation devenue insoutenable pour
certains quand je rentre dans l'immeuble
c'est insupportable on voit des déchets
de nourriture des odeurs désagréables
d'uriné d'excréments des restes de
drogue
quand j'étais enfant la ceca à torcy
était déjà réputé pour son trafic de
stupéfiants il y à plus de 40 ans car le
quartier est connu pour ses trafics de
drogue et ce depuis plusieurs années
mais pour le maire le problème s'est
intensifiée la forme est nouvelle nous
avons affaire à de gros trafiquants
professionnel on va dire ça comme ça
très aguerris armés et qu'ils n'hésitent
pas bien entendu à se faire une guerre
entre eux pour pouvoir justement
posséder ce marché avec une clientèle
qui vient de très loin une clientèle qui
vient de très loin
grâce au réseau routier empruntables
depuis le creusot avec une gare et une
voie rapide à proximité consommateurs et
trafiquants alimente le réseau local
la commune a décidé d'agir les
patrouilles de police sont renforcées
dans le quartier dès le mois d'octobre
treize caméras vont être installées pour
dissuader les trafiquants mais surtout
les identifier il s'agit dans un premier
temps de mettre la population en
sécurité